[Musique]
hier l'ex maire de levallois a adressé
une déclaration d'amour à son épouse
isabelle sur les panneaux d'affichage
public de la ville à toi isabelle
joyeuse saint valentin je t'aime
patrick voilà sobre et efficace hein il
est visiblement meierhans déclaration
d'amour quand déclaration de revenus je
vais embrasser les impôts regarder
pousser par grégory attention c'est la
première fois que j'en fasse un bonheur
des enfants
attention là j'ai failli attendait
bougeait pas bougé vous êtes trop sympa
[Musique]
et passer commande mcdo hier soir les
tweets de paiement très sympathique non
le tri de burger king qui disait comment
des burger king pour la saint valentin
de même nous on cautionne pas cette fois
ci j'ai fait mcdo si tu pouvais changer
de sexe qu'elle serait la première chose
que tu ferais mais j'ai déjà changé de
sexe trois fois et la première fois que
j'ai changé de sexe dans ma tête j'ai
pissé debout je ferais l'amour à une
femme
jeffrey pipi debout mais je laisserai
pas la lunette jeu mastic ray le manche
mon dieu j'ai dit le manche alors en
fait c'est que j'ai 48 ans et il ya
juste un souci c'est qu'on s'est
revendiqué j'aime les hommes plus jeunes
ça n'est jamais mieux
il m'avait dit il ya 25 ans il en avait
19 c'était demander la carte d'identité
maintien ne laissez pas traîner vos
gamins bonjour bonjour sophy bourg
bonjour delphine bonjour homme-objet un
objet sachant bon boulot et bah oui
maintenant et on est tous pareil donc
objet ça tombe bien parce que je
m'entends très très très bien avec les
excès paris devait établir un dialogue
très logique gold hervé pouchol au jo le
c'est le chroniqueur
qui a parlé grand coeur
je veux apprendre à lire dans le
comportement des femmes 1 ah non parce
qu'aux stars mans et d'el hadji les
femmes sont faites pour être rêvez pas
pour être comprise et ya justement pas
je comprends pas dix huit petits trous
de balle allait l'on retrouvera les
trous de balle plus tard sophistes c'est
la pratique la plus romantique la plus
belle et la plus douce qui soit puisque
tout simplement on caresse l'autre à
l'intérieur
nous sommes à deux doigts de monter
effectivement atteint peut tourner à
deux doigts de montcuq à quelques
kilomètres seulement d'un des plus gros
m'ouvre de france et oui le gouffre de
padirac et 33 mètres de diamètre 103
mètres de profondeur quatre cent mille
visiteurs par an ça ça vaut le coup mon
cul je suis arrivé à un stade où je suis
j'allais à l'église prier et mon voeu
est exaucé l'air depuis jamais aimé
personne d'accord tu vas pas prier pour
si j'ai pris mon jamais les plus fins
que dieu il est coutume à cette image et
celle d'izia un bébé gorille des plaines
de l'ouest n'est dans la réserve de
saint martin la plaine dans la loire un
évènement exceptionnel survenu au mois
de novembre mais dont très peu d'image
avaient pu être prises à cause du coc
vide 2,1 millions c'est le nombre de
français qui bénéficient de l'aide des
banques alimentaires d'après l'institut
de sondages csa c'est un chiffre en
forte hausse et plus de la moitié des
bénéficiaires sont arrivés
à moins d'un an c'est dire l'impact de
la crise sanitaire sur la précarité de
la population le site titre julien
courbet le journaliste français le mieux
payé en 2021
on va voir à combien s'élève votre
fortune julien selon ce site
275 millions d'euros j'aurais sur mon
compte 275 millions d'euros j'ai appris
hier
inutile de vous dire que j'ai engueulé
mon banquier en le disant mais depuis
combien de temps vous à tangente en a
pas pu venir sur les plateaux télévision
à la radio on ne voit que des winners et
donc moi je me suis dit c'est vous en
faites entrer l'accusé ce qui est une
thématique un poil un poil un poil
différentes mais en règle générale à qui
voit-on à la télévision ce sont des gens
qui réussissent des gens rayonnant qui
sont boue qui ont de l'argent à des
carrières incroyable etc
je suis là en tout que moi même et en
tant qu' en tant que fille d'un
pédocriminels donc fi d'un monstre au
sens actuel qu'on donne à ce mot
et quand vous êtes la fille d'un monstre
forcément à un moment vous vous demandez
si vous n'êtes pas un peu monstrueux
vous même l'homme accusé et marc ulva
grand leader syndical admiré par de très
nombreux martiniquais qui ont fait de
lui un héros régional
après vingt ans de silence ses trois
nièces ont brisé l'omerta familiale
justin timberlake présente ses excuses à
britney spears et à janet jackson mise
en cause dans un documentaire justin
reconnaît sur instagram avoir bénéficié
d'un système qui approuvent la misogynie
et le racisme
on lui reproche la manipulation
médiatique de sa rupture avec britney en
2002 qui fait décoller sa carrière au
détriment de celle de son ex
même procédé avec le sein de janet
jackson qu'il dévoile en 2004 si lui
profite du buzz
elle sera bannie de tous les médias
américains
j'ai le coeur qui bat a dit mais là j'ai
l'impression qu'il va déplacer ma
prothèse
pourquoi un en arabe un juif
anwar vaudrait mieux que vous aurez
droit bien que vous voudrez bien que
vous non mais sexualité comme ici parce
que quand je lis vos espoirs est-ce que
j'ai quand même le droit de demander à
ce que les miens passe avant les autres
dans mon pays d'origine
si pour vous être français issus de
l'immigration s'est marqué au stade de
france d'une tête contre le brésil
je ne serai jamais français à vos yeux
je suis français et objectivement comme
disaient les béruriers noirs
j'emmerde le front national c'est pas
mal 17 centièmes pour l'instant sur
vincent cliché maillard